OF THEM ON THE BOARD OF THE
UKRAINIAN ENERGY COMPANY, THE
AUTHOR OF SECRET EMPIRES, AND
THE POLITICAL CLASS HIGHEST
CORRECTION AND ENRICHES FAMILIES
AND FRIENDS.
IF THAT COULD BE MORE A TITLE WE
DON'T THINK SO MUCH FOR COMING
COMING.
WE ALSO SENT YOU MORE OF THE
EMAILS OBTAINED EXCLUSIVELY,
WHEN HE WAS DOING FOR THE
UKRAINIANS.
WHAT DOES IT ADD UP?
>> ISAAC IT ADDS UP TO IT THAT
BIDEN FAMILY CASHING
IN THROUGH CORRUPTION BY PROXY.
JOE BIDEN AND HIS WIFE JOE BIDEN
CAN'T TAKE PAYMENTS FROM FOREIGN
ENTITIES, THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE
DISCLOSED AND THAT WOULD BE EASY
TO CATCH.
BUT YOU SET UP YOUR ADULT KIDS.
IN THE CASE OF THE BIDENS,
JOE BIDEN WAS THE POINT PERSON
FOR THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
IN CHINA, UKRAINE, AND LO AND
BEHOLD THE TWO COUNTRIES THAT
HUNDRED BIDEN ENDED UP DOING THE
MOST BUSINESSES WITH OVERSEAS
ARE CHINA IN UKRAINE.
THE AMOUNTS OF MONEY ARE
ASTRONOMICAL AND THE DEALS THAT
HE GOT GOT ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO
DO WITH HIS BACKGROUND.
HE HAD NO EXPERTISE TO SELL AND
HE HAD NO SKILL SET TO SELL, TO
CHINESE OR UKRAINIANS.
HE WAS BEING PAID FOR SOMETHING,
TALKER, AND CERTAINLY WASN'T HIS
SKILL SETS.
I THICKLY KNOW WHAT HE WAS BEING
PAID FOR.
>> Tucker: I WATCHED OVER THE
WEEKEND, I DON'T WATCH A LOT OF
TV, BUT THERE'S AN IMPEACHMENT
FOOTAGE AND SEEMS LIKE IT WAS
WORTH CHECKING IN AND I SAW A
NEWS ANCHOR AFTER NEWS ANCHOR,
ALL THE CHANNELS.
THEY BACKED DOWN SUGGESTIONS
THAT THERE WAS ANYTHING WRONG
WITH HUNTER BIDEN ARRANGEMENT
WITH THE UKRAINE.
WHILE IT THEY SAID THAT?
>> I THINK THE RULES ARE
DIFFERENT FOR CERTAIN PEOPLE.
DOES ANYBODY BELIEVE THAT THOSE
NEWS ANCHORS THAT THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT DONALD TRUMP AND
DONALD TRUMP JR. GOING TO
UKRAINE AND DON JR. GET IN, BY
THE WAY, HUNTER BIDEN WAS BEING
PAID $83,000 A MONTH.
WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE THE
BANK RECORDS.
THE ACCOUNTS THAT IT WENT INTO.
HIS BUSINESS PARTNER ENDED UP IN
A CRIMINAL TRIAL AND WE GOT THE
BANKING RECORDS.
DOES ANYBODY THINK THE NAME WAS
TROP INSTEAD OF BY THE END THAT
THE NEWS ANCHORS ON THE SUNDAY
MORNING WOULD HAVE THE SAME
ATTITUDE?
IT'S RIDICULOUS, EVERYBODY KNOWS
THE ANSWER TO THAT AND I THINK
TALKER, THIS IS WHAT FRUSTRATES
PEOPLE MORE THAN ANYTHING.
FRUSTRATES PEOPLE MORE THAN
ANYTHING.
YOU KNOW, LOVE, I THINK PEOPLE A
LOT OF PEOPLE LIKE TRUMP OR DO
NOT LIKE TRON.
LIKE THE DEMOCRATS DON'T LIKE
THE DEMOCRATS, BUT THE END OF
THE DAY, THEY STILL WANT TO
BELIEVE FIRMLY THAT WE ARE A
NATION OF LAWS NOT OF MEN.
BUT, IT DEPENDS ON WHAT YOUR
LAST NAME IS IT DEPENDS WHAT
YOUR POLITICAL AFFILIATION IS.
THINK ABOUT DID WE HEAR IN 2017?
AFTER THE 2016 ELECTION,
EVERYBODY SAID YOU CAN'T
INVESTIGATE HILLARY CLINTON,
SHE'S NOT NOT RUNNING FOR
ANYTHING ANYMORE.
SHE'S NOT GOING TO BE IN OFFICE,
YOU CAN'T INVESTIGATE HER.
WHAT ARE THEY SAYING NOW?
JOE BIDEN IS RUNNING FOR OFFICE,
SO YOU CAN'T INVESTIGATE HIM
EITHER.
QUESTION BECOMES, WHEN YOU GET
TO INVESTIGATE ANYBODY AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL FOR CRIMINAL
CONDUCT?
ANSWER IS APPARENTLY, FOR ONE
SIDE OF THE AISLE, YOU NEVER GET
INVESTIGATE OUR PEOPLE EVER.
>> Tucker: YES, LET'S MAKE IT
VERY EASY FOR THE TRAVELING COME
UP WITH THAT PICTURE BACK ON THE
SCREEN.
HERE'S JOE BIDEN AND HIS SON AND
SONS BUSINESS PARTNER.
THE TWO OF THE FOUR GUYS IN THAT
PICTURE WHERE WORKING FOR THE
UKRAINIANS.
IF DID THEY TALK ABOUT IT ON THE
GOLF COURSE?
THERE IS, RIGHT THERE.
SOMEONE ASKED JOE BIDEN THAT.
NOT OBLIGATED.
>> LOOK, YOU KNOW THAT HE LIED
WHEN -- WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE HIS
OWN SON HUNTER BIDEN TOLD THE
NEW YORKER THAT HE DID TALK TO
HIS FATHER ABOUT THE DEAL.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT DEVON ARCHER
IN THE PICTURE HAD A MEETING IN
THE WHITE HOUSE ONE ON        OE
THE WHITE HOUSE ONE ON        ON
MEETING A WEEK BEFORE THEY
JOINED THE BOARD.
FINALLY, WE KNOW IT RELATES TO
THE CHINA DEAL IN THE CHINESE
OFFICIALS AND BUSINESS PARTNERS
TO HUNTER BIDEN ADMITTED WHEN
THEY TOOK THE TRIP TO BEIJING BI
THEY TOOK THE TRIP TO BEIJING BG
THEY TOOK THE TRIP TO BEIJING B,
CHINA, HE INTRODUCED HIM TO THE
FATHER WHILE THEY WAS ON THE
OFFICIAL TRADE.
HE WAS LYING WHEN THEY DIDN'T
CONDUCT BUSINESS, THERE'S SO
MUCH EVIDENCE OTHERWISE.